bhisma tries a new product which is
designed any price which is designed to
bring Europe and China closer together
there are also thank you for your
interest in this well I have to say I
think it's it's important to know what
the role of the Press Club plays they
useful they contribute to building
bridges between media people and their
Nations and this is why the Press Club
grass of zero it was created nine years
ago as part of a two-year presidency of
the International Association of so we
started last year will finish next year
is launching a series of journalism
awards one of them is in fact the Europe
China world with the aim of celebrating
the constructive relations between
Europe and its economic and cultural
partners China plays a pivotal role
nowadays more than ever as a global
income
what we as citizens of Europe want
evolving is turning a blind eye to this
bedrock of civilization the respect of
human rights this is the bedrock of
civilization about meaning in Europe
this is embodied in the European
Convention of Human Rights the role of
journalists is to defend it and this is
clear to all those in this profession we
as International Association of Press
Club only want to help demolished
wherever they are to stick to these
principles and live by them reporting
facts not the wish of the pins
journalists are like and turn stones
when you push them the hidden rock
becomes apparent this is why we want to
encourage them in their work by making
the press
everywhere in the world indispensable
for the respect of the inspirational so
I think we don't describe and your own
informed about well you will be
technicalities timing etc but it is
important that you know that there is
one more reason for appreciating the
work of the press this is a difficult
moment for the press in fact it's more
difficult than in the past few years so
I think this should help try to at least
with little help to create
thank you very much you next which is a
keynote remarks by Abraham you who is
due to the European institutions
esteemed members of the press
distinguished guests dear friends good
afternoon welcome to this our third
digital lunchtime debate I would like to
thank our partner tipic for the relaunch
of the huawei the EU website but Maha
just presented to us how it has been in
the news this last few days and I'm sure
all of you have been following the
developments and the media reports those
among us who cherish the rule of law
should be worried you believe in the
free market in a respect of mutually
agreed rules and the principle of
non-discrimination should you be alarmed
with the behavior of the US
administration against Norway what has
happened to the sacrosanct presumption
of innocence the founding fathers of the
US Constitution would be alarmed when
confronted with the actions of the Trump
administration in ovarian European way
for we has been respecting all
applicable laws and regulations but has
been the cornerstone of our success in
the international market and now our way
is becoming the victim of the bling by
the US average faces this is not just an
attack against Warwick
it is an attack on the deeper
Blueface order and this is the nearest
now it is happening to our way tomorrow
it can happen to any other international
company can we shut the eyes to such
behavior
if we do something what will be they
likely consequences or such a complacent
appeasement in future I live in to
everybody to think about the
significance of this development
compared to today's topic the 5g the
European way this is the second biggest
point I want to make the day for we
aspire to solution it's not just the
best on the budget but it is to the
large extent of you're looking products
many of the technologies are actually
developed by the researchers and
scientists in Europe as you may be aware
for we has been operating in Europe for
nearly 20 years without have twelve
thousand two hundred employees in Europe
70% hired locally in 2018 we procured
over 5.6 billion euros of goods and
services in Europe we have researched
partnerships with 140 top universities
and research organizations across Europe
we want Europe to be at the vanguard of
this funky revolution to boost Europeans
economy and reinforce European InTouch
film leader position leading position
that's why that is why we launched a
campaign to coincide the EU elections
Volvo podgy
votes matter aimed at promoting
awareness of 5g opportunities and the
potential it has for strengthening
European values and solidarity I believe
that the future technologies like 5g
will actually help safeguard
Europe's social model and European Way
of life below Europe's history and how
bike in 1950 robert schumann delivered
his remarkable declaration praising
Europe for the future we are at another
crossroads today now nearly 70 years
later we where the new technologies will
bring tremendous changes to the
societies and the future back in 1950
you know place in ruins after the there
were stations under the tragedy of the
Second World War the old continent
needed to reinvent itself and launch a
new model through which is best values
including freedom courage solidarity
could flourish once more the new lucien
arranged human degeneration paved the
way for what has later become the
european union a 28-nation economy and
cultural powerhouse which continues to
inspire the entire world with human
delivered his declaration in line in May
1950 is proposals to pour coal and steel
production and thereby make war between
the European States virtually impossible
since anew
- Milly and yet so much vision was the
beginning of an incredible success story
following cares about a strong and
united Europe and we are ready to work
with you throughout party the European
weight this is a huge opportunities to
Europe to be says the ICT revolution can
work for Europe the continent is looking
for looking to reinvent itself province
party is a assisting part of the
solution for your rooms contemporary
challenges we had Huawei and stools
understand the security concerns of the
European governments and we are ready to
go for the extra mile because because of
the importance of party as an industry
leader for we stands ready to sign no
spy agreements with governments and
customers in all human four states with
European leaders seem to have a somewhat
different mindset from the u.s. French
president
Amanda Marc Rome at the V Martin
conference in Paris last week since the
France has no intention of launching a
trade or take oh and I quote him our
perspective is not to block our way or
any company launching a trade war treat
or take war with Robbie any country is
not appropriate it is not the best way
to defend national security France and
Europe are pragmatic and realistic we
believe in corporations and
multilateralism possible German
Chancellor Angela Merkel has stated that
I quote for us for upon us the security
criteria are the defensive starting
point in terms of deciding who will
participate in the party deployment we
are pleased that Europe is coming out
with its coordinated approach to party
the European Union has prepared had
proved its capacity of winning European
countries together to develop some of
the most robust and comprehensive laws
like GDD arm euro should continue to
drive the agenda forward the EU should
make decisions for the benefits of
Europe and its own citizens in a very
routine way far away has been respecting
all those apart from that or we must
continue to persevere we are a global
company and our international relations
we are continuing not only we are
continuing to invest in Europe we are
also proactively mitigating the impact
of the decisions made by the Bureau of
the industrial of the US Department of
Commerce let me stress this power is
going to do everything is doing
everything we can to make sure the
negative impact of the decision is
mitigated together with our business
partner including the one from us so in
the last year when we is here to stay in
Europe for Europe we learned the
continent
we will keep our contribution to a
strong and with you we have the
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
how do you respond speaking with any of
the us a signal history yes I think
[Music]
collaboration it was a win-win
relationship it was a long term you know
since and with what's happening our
discussion between always team and
Google team was ongoing because there
was the UH the existing business
contract or relationship between program
Google and other sites a political
instruction order the process interferes
is no ordinary business so it's a it's
not only farmers challenge it's also
Google's challenge it's a shared
challenge for the business because we
are I came the body of the of impact e :
so these kind of challenges as I
mentioned earlier is not only about
power is about in touch with is what
it's about
all the business it's today's for me and
I noticed us nowadays that the vehicle
whether it's from box waving no is from
Toyota becomes also the national
security so this kind of excuses may be
used anytime anywhere soon to anyone
this is a common challenge as I
mentioned so your first question about
the us questions to our yearning
stakeholders I think it's new it's
common understanding for us I have
since before we are a purely private
company we are employed old company and
we fully combined the relation role you
know wherever we operate we believed
that this was our of racing car stone
and it can support our continued success
on this kind of a dimensions is the
challenge from the current US
administration you know by loading our
that the government or our customer
themself Europe is unprecedented
I firmly believe in
since the discussion between Bobby and
Google is still ongoing and I'm thrilled
I would not be able to bring very
detailed information from the public
information is the existing users I mean
the the these models products or which
is already in the market it seems that
there is no bigger impact the future one
I think both team are still working
together
attitude so far but of course history
shows us that when I was reminded by
many video it was kind of methodology
they called extreme pressure from the US
way of you know words from a company I
think this is kind of extreme pressure
moment and I go into you you should ask
you know the White House or the US
government whatever the next step foot
you know right but when we after you
know what happened last week we have a
fool and we're busy are also talking to
our customer which is the top operator
we very confident that's the major
solution like fudgy and the core network
or the of the problem the major solution
for the next generation ICT
infrastructure is still there and is
still fully available from Huawei so our
spot will be even stronger
you know they will say that the great
success with enemy I think probably
nowadays we we are more than ever in our
did to support in order to support our
customers to as a feedback as a feedback
to the trust they put on us and we are
happy to share with you our factories
will not only be available and we are
still going to pay the leadership for a
long period of time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
first of all I want to share with you
where the mentions or we will hit
quality inception this is a fact
nobody can choose where we were born but
as a matter of fact following in Europe
we are also you becoming we have two
thousand and two hundred and research a
development program and I mean
manufacturer a lot of activities normal
is I think ICT industry is one of the
most global related industry if you
compare it to any other ICT company the
only difference may be bolita where they
come is registered we wor have the
global research global supply chain and
all the other green company that we're
also big factory or my per person
I recently so listen the first message I
want to share with you before we we
think ourself as part of I mean European
company is a global company settler and
if you talk about the trade balance I'm
not in relation to talk about the bigger
picture but in in China I mean in ICT
industry as far as I know
our major competitor from Europe like
that very big orders you know last month
from the Chinese operator
one in two billion of beginning as
various other so I think the specific
figure you are interested in with her
range you get more detail information
but I think I saw my knowledge it's it's
quite heavy in the competition situation
Thank You America Wall Street Journal
one question I had is that you mentioned
that what's happening with the US and
the policies are unprecedented can you
withstand the pressure separately by
following this scenario will is it to
launch now and what would you do is for
those things for your device's going
into the future
well you forty and lastly if I may are
you some European companies like you're
saying that they're stopping shipments
of us made components
we can't go back to 15 years ago today
we were since many years ago we were
working with what a 10 different one of
them they called IBM have been working
with us for many many years and with
hundreds of conducted with us in many
aspects R&D supply chain financial and
so on and one word we learn from them is
business continuity management by then
so thanks to the services provided to us
we have started our business continuity
management as a result from those
continuous efforts and investment when
we are now in such an extreme situation
we will be able to seek out the
possibility of provides our customers
the continuous support of course there
might be some minor impacts from some
companies or parks but I can show you
again that's the main solutions or the
leading solutions solutions has its own
coins
business management
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you every year or last year or for
coming to us so as a consequence it's
either Europe Japan always own chips
maybe next year and regarding the
printing system we are still busy on
talking to
[Music]
Google team work out the possible way
and of course if the exclusive if they
are availability of this Google system
it's not in manga they are anymore there
to billions of people in Europe as a
better result
at a matter without euros consumers
hundreds of millions of consumers they
may lose the option of choose the
second-biggest android-based smartphone
provider from the leading features of
our new smartphones that's an extreme
situation so in terms of the the markets
free markets free competition for the
availability for the consumers to choose
there are challenges for these markets I
think they are I know they teach
accommodation in charge of this
if you don't promise me there are these
three questions this is about the OS
itself I know he's for me we do have I
think which I read a CEO meeting he has
mentioned once in front of the media we
have been working on our own OS system
you know from the time members of years
ago they have been working on this and I
don't have the latest information about
the availability you know this OS the
time to market I don't have it in hand
as soon as I
okay so thank you very much for the
questions and answers